MALE SPEAKER: We're
really excited that we've
released Android
L. And now we're
also super excited to announce
that we are releasing Google
Play services 6.5 enabling
you to build better apps.
[CROWD CHEERING]
Yeah.
That's what this is all about.
When you start using all the
APIs of Google Play services,
you will be building
better apps.
And as always, when you develop
using Google Play services,
it will run on all devices,
starting with Gingerbread.
So let's check out the
new features in 6.5.
And let's have some fun
while we're doing it.
High five, Gingerbread man.
So starting off with the
Google Drive Android API,
imagine that your app needs
to upload lots of drive data.
Let's say gigabytes.
Well, in that case,
you may want to ensure
that you're connected
to a power source
and you're on a Wi-Fi network.
Well, now, you can
programmatically
specify these types of
conditions for uploads.
And in this release, it
is also possible to cancel
pending uploads
that you don't want.
So these features allow
you to control and conserve
precious resources, such
as network and battery,
for users of your app.
Another new feature is that
you can now create empty files.
Nope, there's no data in here.
And perhaps saving
the best for last,
we've now added the
possibility to add
public and private
properties to your file.
This is like custom
metadata your app assigns
to a file that can
describe the file content.
And, of course, you can
also use this information
when doing queries.
Moving over to
Google Maps, which
is truly an amazing product.
You can navigate through
the entire world using it.
But sometimes, you
don't want to navigate
through the entire world.
Have you ever wanted
just a small, simple map?
That's exactly what
Lite mode maps provides.
Here is one showing
the Googleplex.
Lite mode maps allow you to
serve a static image as a map.
But it still supports many of
the features of ordinary maps,
including different map types,
such as terrain and satellite.
Markers and polylines
are also supported.
Here, you can see a mark
for Googleplex, for example.
And user location can
also be displayed.
Here, for example, is
where I am right now.
And since Lite mode maps
are based on a static image,
there is no need for
continuous server communication
to update the map.
So you can truly say
that they are Lite mode.
So if you have a
bounded area or maps
that are too small
to interact with,
or if you want to stack a
number of small maps together,
then you should consider
using Lite mode maps.
And guess what?
It is really easy to switch to
full blown map functionality.
The user just needs to
tap on the static image.
Now, we've also
added a new toolbar.
This toolbar works for both
regular as well as Lite mode
maps and enables the user
to quickly open Google Maps
and immediately get directions.
And that brings us
over to Google Wallet.
Previously, we've had
the Buy with Google
and the various Save
to Google buttons.
And now, we're also adding
a Donate with Google button.
That's right.
This makes donating as easy
as buying things, exactly
the way that it should
be, which brings us over
to a much-discussed topic.
Let's go really, really
deep technically.
Let's talk about the Google
Play services SDK and something
that will help manage the 16-bit
method limit of dex files.
[BEEPING]
Previous versions of the
Google Play services SDK
required you to depend on
all of Google Play services
to do one aar file.
So your gradle build file
looked something like this.
Yeah, a single line
that included everything
in Google Play services.
And as we've continued
to add more APIs,
it has proven hard to
maintain a lean app.
Therefore, we have
unbundled this aar file,
so you can select only
the APIs you want to use.
Here's an example
gradle build file
that only uses the maps and
the ads API of Google Play
services.
And while there are
many aspects and ways
to manage the 16-bit
method limit of dex files,
this should make it easier
to keep your app lean,
since you select the APIs you
want to include in your build.
And that's almost
it for this time.
I say almost, because there's
one more thing to cover.
Let's go out in the wild and
talk about the Google Fit API.
Google Fit was officially
released in October,
so now it's high time for you
to develop your applications
and publish them to
the Google Play store.
Here is an application,
for example.
Nathan has a band
around his chest, which
allows a Google Fit application
to measure and record
his heartbeats while
he is doing chin-ups.
NATHAN: Now, it's your turn.
MALE SPEAKER: Hot
dog, do I get to try.
Eeee!
That's it for this time,
but be sure to check out
these resources as well.
Now it's your turn to go out
there and build better apps
using all of these APIs.
And don't forget to
tell us all about it.